sometimes Syria don't know what I'm
saying what'd he say he's talking to a
sling but you send it anyway this should
be fine after I graduated from high
school we got engaged almost 5 years
we're definitely going to be butting
heads a lot everything that we text
about fight wise it's usually something
like really small that one of us blew
out of proportion we argue over food
well she doesn't never know what she
wants it was like I always got to make a
decision for every single meal and she
says I'm tired no she's not tired she's
just the sick of everything he usually
knows if I'm upset I respond back with a
K so this one particular day he decided
that he wanted to surprise me with a
picnic he doesn't normally do this was
one of Gabrielle's hats and Dan and Dan
dan dan dan dan so the text message that
you sent me are you dressed well I just
get dressed
you hungry dan dan dan c SE t sh t a
Glor I'm on my way are you dressed yet
she asked me if she can go get her
something um yeah I guess yes question
mark questioning what question man ho
here Dan I Dan Daniel please help
he finally responds what's wrong stomach
hurts I was just trying to bypass her
trying to eat so I can take it to what I
was surprising for which is a picnic but
when you read um yeah I guess it sounds
sarcastic like um yeah I guess I just
thought he was annoying you that's how I
got an attitude that text was when I was
on a run and I was feeling awful and I
wanted him to like come and help me out
and he did not want to come and help
what am I supposed to do her stomach
hurts I'm supposed to send a magical
pixie or something out to join her on
her run and make her feel magically
better I wanted you to come bring like
food or something though after I ruined
everything he said oh he just messed up
everything I had planned I was gonna do
a picnic I bought all this stuff exactly
I don't reinterred
store-bought lunch meat bread some wine
the whole picnic basket everything for
how to get home just like know all we
they just went down the drain he did end
up coming to meet me at like the last
two miles I grabbed a water bottle and
like a man off and we just walked back
for an apartment if I called it instead
of Texas huh well I would've been more
nice over approaching yeah and good
morning me I know you'd probably eat a
whole spot the whole thing would I want
a 3:16 it's a sucks distinctive out of
stuff I think you just need to find a
way to just like meet in the middle
which is what we literally did I know
we're definitely in the heat of the
moment before my texting back and forth
don't really know what you want to say
to the person so everything just
touchdowns out how you feel typing
random letters helps me not say like or
your the words there's something that I
want to say it keeps like from getting
heated though because I cannot get my
head ahead glorp before you even start
to put the phone down for a second get
your thoughts together you can call the
person it's really hard to stay mad at
him when I can actually see his face I
hear the voice are you wasted
[Laughter]